all right today's topic now this is a
reality tv show that used to be on the
air but got removed
because it was too crazy some of the
episodes led to some real life drama
that was too intense and so yeah
loss of life marriages divorces this the
show was insane right stumbled upon a
whole bunch of episodes
and it's called the moment of truth you
never watched that video
never i watched it live listen this
was the genesis
of the cringe whoa
this [ __ ] was lit all right let's pop in
the episode i'm having flashbacks and
goosebumps just watching
they want to see this okay all right and
let you guys know we're going to be
covering a bunch more episodes
so keep coming back because it's coming
to you soon
[Music]
prior to tonight's show all of our
participants have undergone a rigorous
polygraph exam
they don't know the results of that test
but if they tell the truth
they can win up to a half a million
dollars and if they feel they may not
have been truthful during the polygraph
test
they can change their answers tonight
let's meet our first participant
lauren cleary is a 26 year old hair
salon assistant
i'm frank lauren's husband hello frank
i'm jay uh lauren's father
i'm kim lauren's mother hi i'm monica
and lauren's sister
now i'm tim lauren's brother welcome to
all of you
i'm glad to have you here probably level
one and it has six questions
all year one was two six truthfully
you win ten thousand dollars and that's
a good start
have you ever told a customer you liked
their hairstyle when in fact
you did have you ever flashed a stranger
just for laughs
yes i have
and of course that that's the easy
question softball
have you ever taken off your wedding
ring to appear as if you were single
[Applause]
yes i have
[Music]
frank how do you feel about that
maybe i'm sure she has her reasons and
i'll find out later
if you found this out how would you i
trust my girl so whatever
okay i would it's something i would
discuss with her after yeah
you know but it raises questions yeah of
course but to be honest with you
i'd rather not know
fair i think a lot of people feel the
opposite but i understand why you'd feel
that way i'd rather not but if you did
find out it would raise some questions
yep
definitely okay so this is now it's just
starting to get the tip in and already
right now we're gonna have a long
conversation at home
guys buckle it for those of you just
joining us
we're about to continue with lauren
cleary in her attempt to win 500 000
as i said before this is the most
uncomfortable i've ever been on
television
quite honestly if i had had my vote it
would not have aired
but since the decision was made to
broadcast it i want to warn you
what you're about to see is very
difficult to watch
hey the fact that he gave this
disclaimer when i first watched somebody
he's not now no get ready
do you believe you might have been in
love with a former boyfriend on your
wedding day
[Applause]
still in love with your former boyfriend
on our wedding day a
former boyfriend and he's like oh okay i
know the one
were you aware that she had those
feelings on your wedding day
[Music]
uh no i knew that she did have feelings
for
you know ex-boyfriends and everybody
does i didn't know that you might have
been in love with him
look how uncomfortable he is yeah
because you're literally watching the
destruction of
marriages and families for money and
that's when you realize that this show
is too much but that's a bit and you
have an audience going oh and all this
stuff and it's just
but it's it it it it's too much that's a
bit of acting but whatever
you think he's acting a bit now yes but
there's much more cringey moments that
he is
i think he's cringing because he knows
what's coming you want to continue
well to be honest i am really not
concerned about the money
i just i feel a lot better getting this
everything i need to get off my tests
on national television do you want to
embarrass everybody
huh let me just say it's for the money
do it for the money all right but come
on don't be out here lying
this is your 100 000 moment of truth
and this question will not be asked by
me
oh my
lauren can you tell everybody who this
is
or do i need to do it
i i can't speak right now so this is
your ex-boyfriend frank
[Music]
oh yeah this is payback this is famous
i'm like oh i'm about to shatter your
own world
you watch that oh how you doing you good
yeah all right
can i go in i'm about to go in they
don't even know what's going ahead now
he's looking up seeing all the people
they're going ooh
he's like y'all even though he's the one
who's a home record he could wreck my
poom poom
feel me look at look at the look he's
not happy
he's happy to have his moment on tv
because this is back in the days like
when the internet wasn't like today
that would be big on tv was a big ass
deal yeah
this is payback this is petty you think
i'm petty this is petty petty petty
petty king
if you don't want the answer you still
have the button i don't need to remind
you
if i wanted to get back together with
you would you leave your husband
you could avoid this right now by
hitting the button frank
no i want to know so there's a bun that
any one of the other family members can
hit
in order to skip this question so he had
the offer to skip the question
and no and he said no
[Applause]
why would you hit the button we are
going to know the answer
based off the fact that you hit the
button not answering the question
as answering it frank wanted to hear the
answer to this question
monica why did you hit the button i
don't want to hear that answer
i don't think anyone will want to hear
that answer
we wanted to hear the answer oh yes we
did when you said nobody wanted to hear
that answer
everybody wanted to hear that answer do
you believe i'm the man you should be
married to
well wow
um be honest
and say yes
[Applause]
on a scale of one to
petty queen how petty and spiteful do
you have to be
to announce to the world that you wish
your
husband was someone else
on national tv where his friends and
family are watching
to embarrass him and emasculating like
that
how petty and spiteful do you have to be
it's not and apparently apparently
failure apparently
[Music]
she not even doing it for the money hey
must be the money you know it stop it
knock it off
he's so scandalous she's so scandalous
roll the clip damn that hurts my soul
i mean if i was watching one of my
homies you know
after this this is over if i didn't know
that god had some chuckles but i feel
bad for him but if it was really one of
my homies i'd be getting mad at home
like this
catcher in these streets like that's
that's dirty but
oh wow he knew exactly what the [ __ ] he
was doing
it's crazy mo true
[Applause]
i'm not sure what to say uh first of all
frank is there anything you want to say
at this point
no there's really nothing else i can
really hear so
might as well just go for it have you
guys talked about this ex-boyfriend at
all
yeah earlier on in our marriage but i
mean i didn't know he was still an issue
this is uh what else is there you know i
mean
let's go for it this dude too much of a
nice guy dude no
he's taking his l you stay take your l
he's taking his l like like yeah
i mean at the end of the day you you
should you should you should you should
have known i i guess
but i mean if she didn't show you
hell you call this an l my dude this
this is cruelty
i mean there's there's a difference
between i'm not interested i'm rejecting
you
and the difference between going on
national tipping to your husband that's
just disrespectful honestly and trying
to
injure the character i understand what
you're saying but the fact that you
accepted to go on that tv
like my girl comes up to me and says
listen
there's this show there's this tv show
and you read and you sign
contracts after contracts after pages of
contracts
knowing what you're getting yourself
into you know what i mean my girl
goes up and says you know what we're
gonna participate in this tv show
where if i get to win i get uh half a
million dollars but i have to answer
some questions i'm like what questions
about what
well they're gonna have and you know
what he knows what kind of question was
about to be
asked they he knows to what extent they
have to go
and you accepted that um here's what i
disagree
do you think he knew that these kind of
questions and these kinds of answers
were going to come out the kind of
questions
yes and and the kind of question like i
wouldn't air
out these kind of questions out there if
i have if you have to
say something to me i'm not going to be
i'm not i'm not big on telling all my
to everybody and all the social media if
you guys
tell me tell me in private don't air my
social media you know what i mean
so social media or a tv show or whatever
whatnot there's nothing
what man would go like yeah i'm gonna go
on tv knowing that i may potentially
lose my marriage not even knowing that
is i wouldn't air
anything out there like i don't even
talk about my marriage to my friends
no i keep that so you're going to go on
on tv to talk about that and answer
questions i don't want people
ask me like you said it's me and i agree
with you
and you know what it's me yeah it's me
yeah i'm a special
donut i guess but yeah but even if it
wasn't you like let's see
let's see even even if all that okay and
she still wants to go and still do it
without you
it's still like let's say you said i
don't want to do this show she still
wants to do it
it's still hyper disrespectful for her
to get on tv
and mention this stuff everyone knowing
who her husband is
fair you know what i'm saying fair
enough this is not what i would consider
taking an l
because she's literally putting you on
blast and destroying your credibility to
the world
fair for a wife to do that that's beyond
uh our rejection she's not just coming
that's beyond trifling she's not coming
here to say like i want a divorce
she's ambushing you with the fact that
she wishes you were someone else and
insulting you to everyone yeah
you know so that's where i take it to a
point where i'm like oh you're going far
i see what you're saying right there's a
big difference between like i don't want
this anymore
you know like this but
people have committed over stuff like
that i know since you've been married
have you
ever had sexual relations with someone
other than your husband
i'm gonna have to say yes
that answer is
true
okay lauren she doesn't even look sad
watching her face and looking at her
lack of like emotion regards to how he's
feeling
to me some some some part of me feels
she resents him
and i think she almost loves him there's
a there's a certain level of lack
respect and
a lack of humanity that you have to have
to bear someone like on national tv
and when he's sitting over there
devastated who you call your husband
your life partner or whatever
and you don't even care in my mind
you've hated him for a long time i could
not imagine having someone i care about
i love and they're crying and they're
devastated because of something i did to
them
and i'm just there like unless i got a
beef with them that's big imagine
choosing money not only over your
marriage but choosing money over your
marriage and respecting yourself
and your partner and their dignity and
their and their mental health like
you just threw this mother on the bus
for what is what
i remember it's not even two hundred
thousand dollars you know she answers
any of these questions wrong she's out
yup do you think you're a good person
so your answer is yes
that answer is
false
you didn't even believe yourself you
know what that means right
she lost everything
she came so far
ruining marriage relationship with
everybody
people see her a kind of way and at the
end of the day she didn't even believe
herself
she lost everything for what
you know what's the most shocking thing
about this whole thing she's been stone
cold this whole episode and the moment
she found out she lost the money is the
only time that she showed emotion ain't
that a
didn't care when she destroyed her
husband's self-esteem
his emotions nope her marriage nope when
she lost and failed that question when
she realized she was about to get no
money
actually imagine your subconscious you
over
ain't that i mean if you don't believe
in karma
i mean like i said i don't believe in
karma but now
i'm a buddhist monk
[Music]
you did really the way you do it i gotta
give it to you like
you do super well lauren i am so so
sorry why do you think this came up as a
lie for you when i asked you do you
think you're a good person
because even after everything i have
done
stealing the money and everything i
think that i've become a better person
that's why i think i
am a good person yet it came up as a lie
which means that somewhere in you
you haven't forgiven yourself somewhere
your truth is that you don't think
you're a good person at all
[Music]
was he standing beside her trying to
console her he wasn't about he was
trucking her back
nah nah bro now bro you were simp
nah bro i don't i don't respect that now
you deserve a dungeon nah bro you know
what i was feeling sorry for you this
whole time to vote
we start crying and you go to a hugger
and [ __ ] [ __ ] what
bruh i would have walked off said a long
time ago not gonna lie this
oh hell no oh wow no yeah i remember
that i don't remember
i'm actually cheesed for him and this
happened like 30 years ago i remember
that show
vividly it was in the 90s this ain't it
fam
this ain't it this ain't it this is
definitely not insane
what did i just watch brev nonsense
i'm here for you you did the right thing
poor thing
no such took up for a follow-up for this
couple
and lauren said to a news article
newspaper
i don't believe in divorce but now
frank and i aren't living together with
no plans to reunite
i couldn't be happier see yeah this
girl's
petties she moved back to new jersey
with her parents while frank
25 a police officer stayed in piermont
new york after the show
we didn't talk that much she said he
kept changing his mind
i want to work things out i don't want
to finally she realized
if i tried to work things out i'd be
going back to unhappiness
meanwhile frank just wants to lie low
he's not angry with lauren a part of him
still loves her
but not the moment of truth that shows
out to ruin people's lives
her daughter-in-law disagrees at first i
regretted going on the show clary says
but now i'm thankful
it's sped up the process of finding what
frank and i need
yeah the mom was really pissed you
cannot go
after the show the show was there
but you decided and you knew damn well
you could opt out i don't know man i'm
not gonna put that on the show but
whatever
i partially agree with you but no i
think it could be legal and still
extremely dangerous
i understand i understand that
incentives i understand i understand
that the show was
extremely dangerous yeah i'm like both i
understand the show was extremely
dangerous and shouldn't have been there
yeah i get that because you know it gets
on people's weak point and stuff like
that
it plays on that and i get that but
you decided to go
oh yeah so they both bear
responsibilities so yeah it's really a
50 50 thing i'm not gonna say it's all
the show
or all the girl but i mean yes the show
was [ __ ] up
and it should have been there but you
went there
yeah that's true you're right you're
right yeah no they both bear
responsibility
but i just think advertisers would have
a hard time putting their ads on a show
which is basically about destroying
people's lives
how much money are you willing to play
to wreck your family to wreck your
marriage
to wreck your friendships you know and i
and i just think like
this over valuing of money um uh
um in our society willing to sell
anything or
our loved ones or our kids for cash it
just
it's not a good thing to just put out
there um
but at the same time it also reflects
what people are willing to do for cash
and it's always sad
bro i would never be caught dead doing
anything
real talk especially not for money nope
but
um yeah yeah but uh
it was interesting definitely
entertaining i won't lie
lots to talk about but we want to hear
your thoughts what did you think about
the video that you just saw
uh would you go on the show what did you
think about everything you saw did she
really love him
what was she there for was it
disrespectful was it too much i
don't know that was really intense
[Music]
though